hey don't make a lot of it as we do it
wait what what intro wait were you
actually trying to do it indoor where
you just dig it around making noise
intro yeah yeah so does anyone want to
explain it because I don't feel like you
hit balls as literally all this game is
it's just hitting balls back and forth
it's like it's like Super Smash Brothers
and bass ketball had a really weird
child I never watched basic at all to be
honest I don't really remember it that
well but I I think I watched it bass
ketball tomb in the movie people say
it's a really good movie but I've never
ever ever watched right wait yeah no
boom Danny man you're killing me still
got scared yes oh yeah I forgot you can
hit the bodies back and forth before
they get out of here
oh no I paused oh god is going so well I
[Laughter]
need to stop dying Oh what do you what
you guys doing no no I was trying to hit
it but I couldn't
[Laughter]
that's pretty Pro yeah I totally meant
to do it to stay over here you guys know
I do not have the timing down on that
yet at all what do I do it again I'll
just oh look at me yeah no candy man's
awesome I wish you could kill yourself I
think I think with this group the
strategy would just be stand still and
kill your mother person kill themselves
there's like you'll get it I mean this
is my second match so I don't feel that
bad yeah I still suck we definitely
could turn on the game mode where it's
just like huh it's not tag and anyone
can get hit by the ball whoa
oh Jesus hey I wanna win cool and Mark
totally stomps both of us
no mostly me I've unlocked a new flavor
for candy man yay
unlocks new dice for dice - wait you had
11 hits and eight Jesus you you you
cleaned all of you to hit new mattress I
can't do it I hit it
okay good thing no I'm connecting to
lobby oh all right I'm playing as Scout
kid laughter I mean you after he's quick
he's like super quick that's good for me
that way I can run around and get myself
killed even faster characters I don't
know I am oh do you want to change any
options cuz we can change options at any
time I have no idea what the options
even are
let's not change the rules until we
actually know until I understand all the
rules to begin with I'm down yeah all
right I'm not gonna die well that's not
true yeah I'm gonna try not to die
immediately about that man look at that
parallax scrolling background how cool
is that huh
[Laughter]
get out of here oh sweet Jesus
oh my god fine you have fun over there
buddy sure will that was on purpose even
yes I don't think I understand the
timing of the hip balls is there a
window I am the greatest
yeah-ha-ha greatest by total default
[Music]
okay okay
why do you keep now is some chick hit me
play with my giant hammer is that your
special yeah my guy curves the ball cuz
he's got a table tennis thing
no damn it holy crap oh that is cool
though my god mark Mark's character is
Opie is pretty scary he is a newcomer to
lives you all have one you guys you guys
just go nuts I'll just be over here once
it goes into like quantum speed it's
ridiculous you're supposed to do you
just hit it I mean this fast I guess you
want it you're supposed to bunt it so
you can get a good hit on it or
something but yeah what the [ __ ] oh that
was ridiculous and I want to turn up the
speed of the ball speed is going up yeah
oh my gosh I don't know why you're
complaining wait you seem to be come out
No
dang it this sucks
Katie Oh God in the wrong way Oh God
trying to get better than I am yeah it's
not working guys go nuts that's cool
[Applause]
come on no yes he said dammit I thought
he died - don't worry Bob I'll get
vengeance upon him wait
[Laughter]
what the hell oh that did make it go
instantly all the way up to larious yeah
but well I mean we can keep the speed
I'll cut it in half I increased it to
fold I'll cut it back down to 16 gosh
my turn to be Candyman I want to be a
robot red wind shirt yeah is there
purple robot no ready ready lethal
League Oh which one am i okay good
oh whoa I'm this thing that's moderately
[Laughter]
Bob's got scale god dammit
all right Bob you want to team up
against Wade because for some reason a
lot oh well that would work down team
ship over cut like lost track of the
ball completely it loves it in slow ok
then it slows it down and removes
possession of the ball well I don't want
that yeah look at that look at me doing
subtle moves accidentally and not lying
not dying a lot nice move Bob I never
thought I'd the back BAM I'm either you
guys suck now or I'm awesome
hey why did I fall over like that oh I
think you can hit other players
sometimes but only like when they're
swinging too it has to be like usually
candy man like rules but I can't see
anything
get away from me okay well as long as
Wade loses I'll be totally satisfied
what one wants so so well I'll just dive
in
[Laughter]
no no I jumped over it you don't we just
won't let Wade win hey I did better than
Wade yeah that's all that matters
they've been on for Wow everyone just
dies all the time
yes so now the ball is always live okay
okay touch it ever it's never safe and
so well I was like man I wish we could
make this harder so even our own balls
are lethal yes even your own balls can
kill you wait do not touch the ball at
any time don't anyway for God's sake yay
I feel home Oh No
Oh God again watch this
[Laughter]
[Music]
stupidly the king Bob why are you
suddenly doing so good I was totally
sandbagging you guys no idea out of the
game sir burn up victory baby oh no it's
okay just let him kill himself killing
it lose turn off turn ball pegging back
on I hadn't moved at all that would have
really been perfect that's so much
better
I want to do one thing we're turning up
the ball speed Oh God whoever gets the
Serb should just get all the kills then
probably right probably no actually all
right we'll do
high speed ball tagging off so this is
gonna be quick mm-hmm all right well yes
I'm gonna be for this be a back to the
asylum oh let me have first serve hide
over here you guys have fun with my
character can't come back and swing fast
[Laughter]
if you want I'll hit it first I'm just
gonna bunt it up
[Laughter]
my god prepare to eat [ __ ] and die in
the way of that it's okay I'm awful life
I think keeps going that's fine I got it
now that's what who's stuck in
[Laughter]
[Music]
this gun looks a little more useful than
I think what